first of all they come under the
Convention on the Rights of the Child
and if they're minors they have to be
taken in by the United States they can't
be returned under international law and
there are asylum claims should be
adjudicated if they're found not to be
asylum seekers they have to be taken
care of until they're 18 and then they
can decide what to do with them the
Americans are trying every which way to
think of how they can return them today
the temptation is to eliminate the term
refugee from the radar people are only
talked about as illegal migrants abusive
migrants abusive asylum seekers and I
don't secure any of the media
emphasizing the fact that we're dealing
with people who are actually fleeing
persecution
first of all if we would talk about
Europe with fortress Europe it's
impossible to get in without a smuggler
Europe has really succeeded in almost
sealing their borders in the United
States there is a First Instance
interview that is with a non-aggressive
theoretically situation where the
interviewer is supposed to try to help
the asylum seeker establish their claim
and then if they're rejected at that
level they go to the court to a very
aggressive education but only about 33
percent ever make it through the first
instance so it's getting more and more
difficult even in Britain which probably
had for the better
silent procedures to get refugee status